[Musica]
bene che emozioni di sembra che possa
provare questo personaggio che è
diventato famoso era la copertina di the
court of the crimson king un album lp
che ebbe grande successo alla fine degli
anni sessanta che emozioni esprime
questa immagine sicuramente due una è il
terrore e l'altra è senza dubbio si dice
la rabbia collera ira questo è il
termine sicuramente più corretto in
italiano
arriviamo al rapporto tra collera ira
rabbia parliamo con il senso comune
quando noi ci sentiamo particolarmente
terrorizzati e arrabbiati quando vediamo
che ri cosmo che è quell orizzonte di
ordine di prevedibilità all'interno del
quale possiamo essere creativi possiamo
cambiare l'ordine delle cose e prevedere
quello che accade viene corrotto dal
causa cioè vale a dire
dall'imprevedibile e quanto più il caos
è importante e destrutturante tanto più
ci sentiamo oltre che terrorizzati
chiaramente anche arrabbiati che cosa
prova a questo cane evidentemente molto
arrabbiato ma anche molto spaventato
che cosa sta accadendo è bene dovete
sapere che nei primi sei mesi di
quest'anno sono esplose le ricerche
intorno al terrore ma anche intorno alla
collera hunger in particolare questo è
il termine che bisogna utilizzare con i
motori di ricerca per rintracciare gli
esiti di studi e di analisi che sono
state fatte in diverse popolazioni
in tutto il mondo sostanzialmente ciò
che si sta rilevando è che uno degli
esiti forse tra i più importanti del
covip sì sicuramente è la paura
sicuramente c'è molto dolore
molta depressione dovuta anche tra
l'altro al lutto ma dobbiamo sapere che
la rabbia è una delle è uno degli studi
è una delle emozioni di base più sentite
proprio per coloro che soffrono per le
perdite per il lutto ebbene ci si è resi
conto che uno dei problemi più
importanti che dobbiamo gestire dopo il
compito speriamo che sia questa la fase
che stiamo vivendo è proprio la rabbia
hunger l'iran e che cosa sta vedendo
dicevamo questo cane per provare tanta
rabbia e tanta ira sta vedendo un cigno
nero
no non sto parlando ovviamente di un
animale non sto parlando di quello
splendido animale eccezionale che
colorato di nero ci sorprende quando lo
vediamo magari insieme a dei compagni
candidi ebbene la teoria di nassim taleb
la teoria del cigno nero indica appunto
quell'evento caotico vale a dire casuale
imprevedibile che viene dal nulla
direbbe il mio maestro per confutare
questa teoria appunto emanuele severino
e che dunque scompagina interamente i
piani quello scompaginamento procura
terrore e
rabbia appunto e quando si ripete
all'infinito cioè vale a dire quando il
cosmo è totalmente corrotto dal caos noi
viviamo un senso di impotenza gli
psicologi parlano di impotenza presa e
per non vivere questo vissuto e
cerchiamo il più possibile dice taleb di
spiegare il che cosa ha causato
quell'evento in modo tale da poterlo
prevenire questa previsione ci aiuta
dunque a sentirci più potenti più capaci
di affrontare il futuro e quindi di
tornare ad abitare un cosmo piuttosto
che il caos
chiaramente la paura e l'imprevedibilità
rendono la vita impossibile per l'uomo
perché abbiamo perso la maggior parte
degli istinti e dobbiamo necessariamente
vivere nella nostra società prevedibile
anche se a volte l'essere troppo
prevedibili ci annoia
il problema è il primo test qua stiamo
per citare un altro evento ted
il problema è che per quanto noi
possiamo dire che il co video sia stato
un cigno nero assolutamente
imprevedibile che cosa accade proprio
per non vivere in un profondo senso di
impotenza e anzi capire che cos'è il co
vieta abbiamo cominciato a rivangare nel
passato e ci siamo resi conto che
proprio all'interno del ted era il 2015
un certo punto era venuto fuori molto
chiaramente da bill gates che
erano ormai state fatte molte previsioni
dagli epidemiologi quali ci allertavano
e dicevano attenzione siamo in ritardo
deve arrivare molto presto una pandemia
quindi preparate i piani antipandemici
chiaramente siamo tutti molto risentiti
e molto arrabbiati perché quando arriva
una notizia infausta di questo genere
non si sa quando non si sa come non si
sa che cosa sarà però vi possiamo dire
con certezza che avverrà dovrebbe
attivare dei processi di riduzione del
danno cioè ci sarà un caso
arriverà qualcosa che assomiglia ad un
cigno nero ma possiamo limitare i danni
e questo è quello che non è successo nel
quarto mondo non dico nel terzo mondo
non dico soltanto in italia ma
addirittura in tutto l'occidente abbiamo
addirittura avuto dei capi di stato che
hanno sfidato il cigno nero dicendo sono
tutte bufale e così è successo quello
che è successo
bene la rabbia però un grande limite non
risolve i problemi e non aiuta a
prevedere voi sapete che quando si è
molto arrabbiati sia un po come questo
personaggio che vide scrive descrivevo
della lp the king king crimson
ed è appunto incapace di farci ragionare
vediamo che cosa sanno fare gli
psicologi rispetto all incapacità di
gestire le emozioni specialmente quando
sono quelle primarie
voglio ricordarvi un evento di pochi
mesi fa grazie a dio abbiamo scoperto
questi vaccini sono stati molto efficaci
molto bravi senonché in toscana per la
stanchezza una infermiera ha inoculato
ben quattro dosi in un colpo solo a
questa giovane tirocinante che si è
fidata questi giovani che si fidano di
noi adulti e che dovremmo guidarli tutti
ci saremmo aspettati intanto una
esposizione mediatica della giovane
psicologa e poi anche un
manifestazione del suo risentimento
magari addirittura la volontà di
rivalersi dal punto di vista legale
contro l'infermiere invece non lo ha
fatto ha taciuto è stata zitta e ha
perdonato che cosa sa la psicologa sa
che la rabbia non risolve assolutamente
niente
non solo non risolve ma aggiunge
problemi ai problemi che già abbiamo
quindi noi psicologi la prima cosa che
diciamo è attenzione ok la rabbia va
vissuta ma innanzitutto va riconosciuta
e poi si può gestire la si può elaborare
e questo dà grande potere specialmente
quando si deve fare in riduzione del
danno perché qualcosa di inatteso ha
scompaginato le nostre previsioni la
nostra vita quotidiana
già così difficile bisogna saper
lavorare vedete la seconda immagine è
quella di un iceberg
bisogna saper lavorare a livello
inconscio e non solo ma gli psicologi
sappiamo che non basta sapere che la
rabbia non risolve non basta sapere che
ci aspettiamo che arrivi il cigno nero
perché inevitabilmente rischiamo di fare
come abbiamo già fatto
qualcuno dice abbiamo l'esperienza non
faremo gli stessi errori e non è vero
faremo gli stessi errori se non
diventiamo consapevoli del meccanismo
inconscio che ci ha portato ad essere
così inefficaci dal punto di vista
psicologico molto efficaci dal punto di
vista medico molto inefficaci come
popolazione anche occidentale dal punto
di vista psicologico perché siamo stati
così incapaci di gestire il terrore di
gestire la notizia la notizia peggiore
che potessimo ricevere attenzione c'è un
virus altamente infettivo che sta
circolando dobbiamo fare subito qualcosa
immediatamente per fermarlo e non
l'abbiamo fatto abbiamo fatto passare i
fatidici 2 3 mesi iniziale che hanno
trasformato il contagio in epidemia la
terra management fiori spiega molto bene
questo fenomeno
tutte le volte che ci arriva una notizia
che ci dice attento 6 immortale 6 il
pericolo noi inevitabilmente buttiamo
nell'inconscio questa consapevolezza
cioè la rimuoviamo non lo teniamo
presente
sfidiamo la spola sorta e non solo la
sfidiamo ma addirittura viviamo come se
il pericolo non ci fosse questo pensate
drammatico da sapere è assolutamente
normale e non c'è una colpa
sostanzialmente non c'è una colpa perché
è una relazione primaria che abbiamo e
che attenzione ignoriamo non sappiamo di
essere vittime di questa strategia che
adottiamo quotidianamente che ci fa
sentire sempre salvi sempre disponibili
alla vita è sempre in sicurezza
ebbene la paura della morte ci fa
censurare perché ci paralizza tutti i
messaggi che ci allertano rispetto al
pericolo questo lo dimostra terra merge
mansioni ormai con centinaia di
dimostrazioni empiriche che cosa
promuovo dunque promuove un percorso dei
percorsi di destre ducation per tutti
noi di comunità per dire signori
cominciamo a ragionare ragionare su
questi meccanismi inconsci cominciamo a
riconoscerli perché poi sono inconsce le
reazioni
cioè non le controlliamo diventava
diventiamo noi stessi figli e neri per
noi stessi
questa immagine che vediamo e di li hua
yang che come sapete è il primo medico
oftalmologo che dichiarò attenzione è
arrivato il cigno nero
dobbiamo fare qualcosa e farlo tutti
insieme
la prima cosa che hanno fatto e poi
hanno seguito questo esempio molti
politici anche occidentali è stata
quella di negare che questa fosse una
notizia da tenere in considerazione è
appena passato un anno dalla sua morte
perché in maniera estremamente eroica
quando è stato riabilitato dopo essere
stato rimosso dal suo lavoro per aver
dato questa notizia dopo essere stato
riabilitato non è stato capace neanche
lui che sapeva di salvarsi dal covip
quindi è molto importante che noi come
cittadini di comunità che i nostri figli
che i nostri nipoti che i nostri amici
che i nostri politici ma i giornalisti
comincino a ragionare su queste
dinamiche inconsce assolutamente
incontrollabile senza colpa e che
riusciamo anche a considerare che se ci
arrabbiamo per le nostre reazioni
inconsce sicuramente non possiamo
risolvere il problema essere fatalisti o
essere emotivi non aiuta a gestire gli
eventi del caos che distruggono il
nostro cosmo che vuol dire il disordine
l'imprevisto che distrugge i nostri
ordini e le nostre capacità di ragionare
essere fatalisti e dire no ce la faremo
andrà tutto bene tutto sommato può aiuti
aiutare a vivere con un po meno di ansia
qualche ora ma ci procurerà
inevitabilmente a un certo punto dei
problemi che non potremo e non sapremo
gestire ecco dunque che dobbiamo
recuperare una cosa che anticamente si
chiamava memento mori
ricordati che sei fragile
la tua vita un numero limitato di giorni
devi sapere che lo vuoi ignorare
e questo ti fa commettere errori e
ironia della sorte ti fa morire prima
grazie
[Applauso]